Hello, everyone.
20 years ago, Latin American cinema
exploded around the world.
From Mexico,
the names of Alejandro González Iñárritu
Guillermo del Toro, Alfonso
Cuarón rapidly became a reference
for everyone around the world
and not just from Mexico, from Brazil,
there was Walter Salles,
Fernando Meirelles, Padilha.
From Argentina, Trapero,
Lucrecia Martel.
Many names from Latin America that were
suddenly setting the bar really high.
There was no cool festival
if it didn't have a Latin American film.
Names like "Wild Tales, "Roma,"
"A Fantastic Woman."
Titles like "Embrace of the Serpent,"
"No," "The Milk of Sorrow."
Latin American films have been
celebrated around the globe
and especially at the Academy Awards.
But we're not stopping there.
Many filmmakers are crossing over
and expanding their careers
into the English language industry,
and those stories need to be heard.
In the following panel,
the amazing producer Rosa Bosch will have
a passionate debate with four filmmakers
that are already shooting in English
that have so much to say
and experiences to share.
So please stay for the panel,
enjoy the panel
and remember, tell your own stories.